journalist teacher and the author of 20
books
call in and talk with him about the face
of battle
the second world war
the history of warfare
and his new book intelligence in war
for the next three hours join john
keegan our guest on in-depth sir john
keegan why do you think you became a
writer and a military historian
uh
well
i've
from from
quite early on i mean
it's early childhood really i'd i i
found writing easy i find
i found putting
pen to paper quite easy
um
i'd formed an interest in military
history
earlier than i can remember really my
father had been a soldier in the first
world war i was growing up in the second
world war
uh in a part of britain where
the american army was gathering to
invade normandy so i had the spectacle
of a gigantic
military force before my eyes at all
times
and then when i
started to grow up when i was
going to university
having to choose what i was going to
study military history seemed the
obvious thing
to settle on and i did indeed study
military history as a special subject at
oxford
um
and then when i went out into the world
when i left oxford and just having to
think about a job i thought well would
it be possible to get a job as a
military historian and
to my
surprise i found that there indeed were
a few openings in military history and
one of them was at
sandhurst which is britain's military
academy britain's west point and i did
get a job there and i did
then spend a long time
a large portion of my life
at sandhurst
a professionally employed as a military
historian and
beginning to write about it that's how i
became a writer
if you look at the situation right now
in iraq and this country how does what
you found in intelligence and war apply
to the current world
well of course
i think much more so curiously in
britain than it does in america because
there's been a terrific role
about the role of intelligence
in getting britain into the war in iraq
which i don't think there has been in in
the us
in britain where there's a strong
opposition to the war
uh
those who oppose it say that tony blair
the prime minister
took britain into war on on a false or
a biased intelligence report
having to do with
the chemical weapons the
weapons of mass destruction threat
and it sparked the most dreadful
political
crisis uh
there's a judicial inquiry the prime
minister's had to appear in court it's a
almost
the same sort of
atmosphere as you get in
in america if there's danger of
impeachment of the president
uh and it's all to do with intelligence
saying intelligence has been very very
crucial in britain's part in in in going
to war in iraq i think less so in the us
but nevertheless in the us too
the president said
he had to
he had to
take take the
us forces to the gulf to deal with
saddam because saddam
threatened
the use of weapons of mass destruction
in his neighborhood and further afield
and that was all based on intelligence
assessments
you were born in 1934
where in great britain i was born in um
in london
um i was born in cedars road clapham
i can see
uh where i was born on the train going
up to london from where i live now
and
i
was was common then when i was born in a
little nursing home but i didn't live my
parents didn't live far away and we
stayed in london until
1939 the outbreak of war when we went
down to the country and spent the whole
of the war in the country
very near where i
live now
then in somerset now in wheelchair but
perhaps only
50 miles apart when we're united
2000 the millennium owners list 2 000
what does that mean knighted
you you well you you put sir in front of
your name you become i became sir john
keegan
which is
rather uncomfortable and then you forget
about it i think quite quickly
you go to the palace
uh buckingham palace
uh
you wait in in line with lots of other
people who've got
medals or decorations and when the time
comes you
go go forward
the queen taps you on the shoulder with
a sword and um you become
in my case sir john keegan do others
forget it i mean you know you say you
forget it yes i think so i mean in my
village
i live in a little in a little farming
village
um
everybody continues to call me john a
save all was done uh i think the only
the only people who
who pay attention are
the um
middle-aged personal assistants of
important men who are scrupulously
polite they say
may i speak to sir john keegan on the
telephone
nobody else bothers
just before we went on the air you said
that there is a
a letter hanging on your wall uh and
we're going to show some video in a
moment or two of your
place of doing your work from the
letters from bill clinton what was the
reason for it
in 1994 uh bill clinton was coming to
europe as president
to
take part in the
50th anniversary
ceremonies for d-day
and he asked a group of historians
including me to go to the white house
and brief him about what he should say
at the various locations
uh
the other five were americans i was the
only non-american there i said uncle
fezal it was a tremendous honor to be
asked to the white house secondly of
course he was a tremendous
interest because
i never met a president i'd never
been in the white house i'd never seen
how the white house worked
and then it was personally interesting
about being bill clinton he because he
he conducted the thing very very
competently
he said to uh
he asked each person
um
who was an expert on on on a different
thing
what he should say about
their expertise
he asked me
what i as a as a british citizen thought
i said well don't forget the canadians
because one of the three beaches was a
canadian beach and they're extremely
proud of it
and
i also said don't forget the polls
because the
polls played a heroic part in the
culmination of the battle of
of normandy
and um he did in fact in his speeches he
did mention both the canadians and the
polls so perhaps my advice was useful to
him you tell a story in the opening of
your new book on intelligence about a
meeting you had years ago with former
cia director
william casey yes
and the role that historians played in
his life and the role that your book's
played in his life tell us the whole
story yes well i was asked to go to um
to langley to cia headquarters i met a
cia
training officer
who who'd said that he thought i could
be useful in in talking to cia trainees
training analysts
um so i went to see them once and then
they asked me to go again and this time
when i arrived my escorting officer said
you're going to meet the director
and
we eventually found our way to william
casey's office and i was taken in to
meet him and he he began to speak to me
and i couldn't understand what he was
saying
uh and i thought that he was uh
because i
was at that stage
the defense correspondent of the london
daily telegraph i thought perhaps he was
going to going to convey some important
uh
scoop or intelligence
news to me um so i got closer and closer
to him
and
eventually when i was almost sort of
sitting on his desk he i realized that
he was not talking to me about
intelligence at all
he was talking to me about writing
military history books because he
himself was an author and he'd written
he gave me a copy
he'd written a book called
when and
where and how the war was fought it's
actually an excellent book about
relating the geography of the war of the
revolution to
the modern road system of the united
states and um
describing the current state of the
war the revolution battlefields
uh
but of course it was
i was slightly taken aback i was
thinking that i was communicating at the
highest
level of intelligence and discovering
that
that
instead this was a conversation between
fellow authors when i got outside and
there was a group of cia officers
waiting i i i said but they said
what did he talk to you about and i said
i couldn't really understand of which
they
there was sort of collective outburst of
laughter and um they then explained to
me that he was known as mumbles
or the only man in washington who
doesn't need a secure telephone he was
notoriously
incomprehensible
you also talk in your book a lot in all
your books about the fact that you
didn't fight in any war
but i get the sense we last talked 10
years ago for book notes which by the
way for our viewers is on the web they
can go in and look at the entire
transcript under booknotes.org but have
you seen
war up close
at all in your life
well it depends what you mean by up
close have you heard shots fired in
anger but i have and
i have
now clip kipling roger kipling who was
the i think one of the
most imaginative of all
uh
writers about war and soldiers
only ever saw
fighting once and then all he saw was a
puff of smoke
among trees
sort of at a distance in during the war
in
1900 or 1901.
um
i have
of course stephen crane who wrote
the red badge of courage generally
regarded as the greatest of all war
novels
had never been near a war and he
afterwards admitted that
all he knew about violence he'd learnt
on the football field at yale
um
but no i have um
i was in
lebanon in 1894
at a very violent stage
and there was a lot of shooting then and
i
i did
i did see quite a lot of shooting and
i'm i'm not going i'm certainly not
going to say i was shot at
but i was shot over or shot near
i was shot over by the uss missouri
which um i was
sitting
uh
with a u.s liaison officer on the head
on the top floor of the lebanon ministry
of defense looking out to sea and i
suddenly saw clouds of smoke
wreathing the enormous shape of the uss
missouri
um
and i said what's the missouri doing and
he looked at it he said it's firing its
main armament
well
it was the
the first time that the the the
sixth fleet had intervened in the
in the
war in lebanon which was a civil war as
you know
but at that moment the uss missouri the
most powerful battleship in the world
with its sister ships
had fired its 16-inch guns over our
heads out into
the shuff mountains to
deter i think the druze from
attacking the legitimate government
the reason i bring it up is because
there's been some discussion in this
country
often by people who are opposed to our
involvement in iraq that people who have
not gone to war
have not been in the military
shouldn't be one sending
americans into war and they've named
people like dick cheney and
and paul wolfowitz and
many others that uh are involved in the
government and i would ask you what you
think of that and also about historians
that have never been in war and you've
discussed this yeah well we have exactly
the same response in our country um and
i find i'm constantly being asked to
write articles for newspapers
uh on this theme should uh
or is britain's foreign policy skewed by
the fact that we
are
current generation of politicians has
not only never been to war but
not usually being in the army they they
were
they
they're too young to have
uh
had to obey the draft
and that's true
and of course it is true in in in in
this country too with the
the with odd exceptions donald rumsfeld
was a
was a navy pilot
uh not in war i think but he certainly
knows about flying on and off carriers
which is a pretty dangerous occupation
uh
i i i haven't been to war
except i've been to wars as chorus as a
correspondent
uh i haven't been a soldier on the other
hand i spent 25 years
uh as a teacher at santos which is our
west point
our military academy i lived
side by side with soldiers for 25 years
of my life i know how they think i know
what they talk about i uh
i have no difficulty at all in
understanding soldiers that that's
really answering your question about
historians rather than about politicians
but as far as i'm concerned i
i don't feel i'm unqualified i feel in
fact that i'm very qualified simply
because of this intimacy that i've had
with soldiers unusual difficult to get
um i do find that historians who haven't
had some intimate contact with the armed
forces and write about war
lack something
politicians
well the one thing nobody ever said
about mrs thatcher was that
she was unqualified to send our
soldiers and sailors to the falklands in
1982 because she hadn't been
in the forces i mean what everybody said
about mrs thatcher was what an
absolutely remarkable war leader she was
as
curiously women
i won't say often but when women do have
to serve as war leaders
accuracy they often make very very good
ones i mean mrs thatcher was
outstandingly good mrs indira gandhi of
india was a was a very determined war
leader
uh and so on so
no i don't think it i don't think it's a
disqualification
uh
in
the post-war generation which
is in charge now
that there's a lack of
direct knowledge of what war is like in
just a couple minutes we're going to go
to the calls the numbers are going to be
up on the screen
uh and you can begin dialing now
this is the first book
1976 that sir john kegan wrote called
the face of battle
and
what what did it say
in a nutshell
it said that
the most important
emotion in war is fear
but um
the thing to remember about soldiers is
not that they're being brave or or that
they're being heroic but
they're feeling extremely frightened uh
and that uh
most soldiers uh
i think when they tell the truth about
their experience of war
will tell you that they were frightened
the whole time
the other books in
which book of yours sold the most
curiously i think one of my recent books
see the first world war
to my
i wrote about it because
my father was in the first world war and
like most
british people i'm
fascinated by the first world war
killed so many of our fellow citizens
uh but
i i wrote it simply because i wanted to
write it i i i said to my publisher
well i'm afraid it won't sell very well
in america
i have a huge american readership so
that was rather important consideration
but i was quite wrong it sold
tremendously well in the united states
it sold i think nearly 200 000 copies in
the united states and
i think
that
that has developed i don't think it was
there 20 years ago 30 years ago but
that has developed an extraordinary
interest in the first world war in the
united states
why it's difficult to say i
it's
of course the american civil war in the
first world war
have
similarities they were both
terrible social experiences
frightfully costly and blood
uh left uh huge
uh consequences of all sorts
and i think that those similarities have
become apparent to americans and maybe
that's part of the explanation but i
don't think it's the whole explanation i
think this
growing american interest in the first
world war is is very mysterious
but interesting sir john king will be
with us for another 2 hours and 45
minutes let's take a phone call from
stanford connecticut first up stanford
you're on the air go ahead please
stanford are you there
yes hello okay please uh my interest in
the first world war and i really enjoyed
your book very much
there were two questions that i had and
i've studied this in college and in
graduate school
is why did germany stop the offensive in
the beginning of the war
and at the end of the war with the
collapse of the german military
what prevented the allies from occupying
germany
and i think it's a it's an apt question
now because we in america we have a
problem finishing wars
sure
why did germany stop the offensive in
1914
the germans have agonized over that a
very great deal of course the germans
had expected to win outright and quickly
in 1914
they thought they'd encircle the french
army and force it to surrender in the
open field they didn't uh the the french
army staged a counter-offensive at the
battle of the man and the germans found
themselves retreating
um
and
uh
high command
sent an emissary lieutenant colonel
hench
to see
what the situation was and to give
advice and hench
more or less on his own authority
said
they had to stop retreating there was no
point in hoping to stage a counter
offensive of their own and they better
dig in where they were and so they did
they dug in on what was then to become
the line of the western front for the
next four years that's why they stopped
the offensive because colonel hench told
them to stop the offensive uh
the
second point about why
didn't the allies occupy germany i think
i think because they knew that
if they pushed the germans too far
the armistice might break down
the um
the german army had not been defeated in
the field as
we were to be reminded many many times
in the subsequent years it was after all
the the the theme of hitler's uh
appealed to the germans we were an
undefeated army and yet we were
humiliated as a nation um
we this is intolerable we must do
something about it
in
1918 i i think the allies felt that if
they
uh if they tried to occupy the hail of
germany then the germans would
turn
would recover their fighting spirit
and would force the allies to fight a
war
at a disadvantage
deep in the interior of germany and so
they only went as far as orion
santa barbara for sir john keegan good
morning
good morning um could you talk about um
the book the great war in modern memory
by paul fussel and the various names
never had any impact or influence over
your thinking
especially in how it deals with the
memory of war as it comes down to us by
individual combatants especially as it
returns to the kind of irony that seeps
into the consciousness of combatants as
the years pass by and how they remember
the individual events
sure
i'm delighted to answer that question i
i know paul fossil well he's a friend of
mine he's visited me in england i
visited him in the united states
and
uh paul fossil's great war in modern
memory is rightly regarded as
one of the most
important books of the second half of
the 20th century both as a
a piece of military history which it is
in a way
uh but also as a
work of highly perceptive literary
criticism
which it is also it's a remarkable book
it straddles two cultures two
disciplines and it does so in a
brilliant way
um
it was an enormous success both
uh um commercially and critically and it
deserved to be so
what i think paul was so clever
at was in
relating
what people said about the war what
writers like robert graves or siegfried
sassoon said about what had happened to
them
as people
to the objective experience paul
knew the writers
intimately well he's a professor of
english literature and lots of
professors of english literature know
writers intimately but what was
really striking about
paul's treatment was that he also knew
the history of the first world war
intimately so he could put the two
together in a in a
very very uh
uh
connected way
and that's why the book
has always been so popular and is
deservedly popular where is he located
he
uh used to live in in
new jersey
and teach in philadelphia i think i but
i think he's retired now
boston massachusetts go ahead please oh
hi yeah i'd just like to commend the
guest on having the college to criticize
deborah lipstad
in the wake of the irving lawsuit um i
think you said something on the lines
that she was as dull
and as only the self-righteous and
politically correct can be
um could you tell me whether you was uh
surprised in the outcome of the irving
trial thanks a lot please explain to the
audience this is a very um this is a
very sensitive and difficult subject
david irving is of course the uh
he is the author of number of books uh
uh
of different themes one of which
is called hitler's war
of which like many other modern
historians i'm a great admirer
um because it's an uh as
lord dakar hugh trevor ekbar said it's
as if it's as if hitler had written an
autobiography that that that's the
quality that uh david irving's hitless
war has but nevertheless he's a highly
controversial figure he's he's uh
condemned for what appear to be
pro-nazi and anti-semitic positions
uh i was forced to give evidence in his
trial
when um two years ago i think
uh i he he asked me if i would give
evidence and i said no i would not
uh he then issued a subpoena
which is a
legal device which
means that the
the person on whom is served has to
appear in court
and so i was obliged to go to park to
court and to
give evidence that's to say to answer
his questions which i did
and i then wrote an account of
my experience in court
in which uh
i tried to explain what i felt had
happened but i did indeed say that i
thought deborah lipstadt was a rather
boring writer and didn't have anything
original to say whereas of course irving
for all his faults for all his faults is
not a boring writer
your book
the second world war came out when and
how well did it do
it came out in
on the
second world war
1939 1980 it came out in 1989 on the
50th anniversary of the outbreak of the
the second world war
and i think it sailed very well in the
united states not very well in england
not as well in england because
many people wrote
books to commemorate the outbreak of the
second world war in one of whom was
martin gilbert and uh his book and mine
were published almost simultaneously but
he's slightly ahead of mine and it did
better
and quite justifiably martin is a
wonderful historian and the most
charming man and i don't in any way
i bear no grudge
at all portland oregon are you there
portland i guess is not there let's go
to san mateo california are you there
yes how are you you're on the air okay
hello hi this is honor brian lamb and
john keegan at the same time
uh
if germany could have at all avoided the
first world war
um would they have
gained european hegemony through
increases in manufacturing it seems that
i've read things that their steel
manufacturing
would have outpaced britain and uh and
what would have uh an ascendant
kaiserine germany
have meant for the world
well
that's a very thoughtful question one
much increasingly discussed i think both
in europe and america
and there is a great deal of reason to
think that had germany restrained itself
uh
that it would
uh incrementally have
gained
more and more power over the continent
of europe it was the second largest
economy in the world by then the britain
was overtaken as the world's largest
economy in 1870
and in 1914 of course the united states
was
by far the largest economy in the world
followed by germany with britain third
um
and in terms of coal steel and iron
production
germany
greatly outstripped britain
and all other european countries it also
for example this is
often forgotten or not known at all it
had the second largest
commercial fleet in the world
the british
always
proud at the time and proud to remember
that in 1914
the british merchant navy
of 20
million tons of
merchant shipping was by far the largest
merchant navy and that was why they
needed
the enormous
royal navy that they had to protect it
but we forget that the germans
had the second largest and a very very
considerable fleet it was too so i think
in these ways both as a producing nation
and as a trading nation
germany was very very powerful and
getting more powerful in 1914
and had they had they been able to
restrain themselves from going to war i
think
uh simply i think you're right i think
simply by sort of natural
uh natural
increase they
they would have come to dominate the
continent
there's a fellow named chris basford
who has been somewhat critical of you
over the years
and your positions on klaus woods for
some reason i want to just show you a
quote and
ask you uh to explain this
some of keegan's bitterness can be
attributed to mere quirks of personality
for the profoundly
civilian keegan clearly is a moon struck
romantic about soldiers or even more
dangerous a disillusioned romantic the
rational side of klaus whitsian theory
which ruthlessly subordinates these
unique creatures to the drabness of
government policy must be repugnant now
he's a professor at the national war
college uh do you know this fella no but
i know his opinions why isn't the
opinions of of many others i'm
i'm well aware of them why is he so
strongly critical of your position on
classwoods
well it's a it's a bit theological this
um uh
it's very like the sort of arguments you
get inside uh
churches about points of
dogma or teaching um
my criticism of cliffswitz who is
universally recognized as the most
important
thinker theoretical thinker about war
that has ever lived
is that he
uh over emphasizes
the political element in war
uh i don't think that uh
these um
close of its people who follow class of
its tend to say that all wars
have a have a political
cause and purpose
i don't think that's true i think that
uh
uh
the inner nature of war
uh
is it a is it is that it is a sort of at
an
even more profound level than the
political
uh and i like to say that it's if you
need to give it a name that it's
anthropological it has to do
with the nature of man himself not with
the nature of how he organizes his
public life
um because you can have a perfectly good
war
with uh high levels of commitment on
both sides and frightful carnage
and no in fact no
objective
political input at all let's go to
pittsburgh you're next pittsburgh thank
you very much for taking my call this
question for mr keegan is directed to
towards his methodology of writing
military history
could you please outline for me the
various steps in research you undertake
in writing
such classics as the face of battle
mask of command and price of admiralty
thank you very much well thank you
that's very flattering of you um i think
i tend to
from somewhere or other
uh an idea
comes to the surface and stays there for
uh our time and if it stays there long
enough you think well
i really must write a book about this um
[Music]
i think that's where the impetus to to
write comes from
and sometimes the idea sort of
stays for a time and then goes away and
you you you feel that well that
might have worked but i don't think it
would really because i didn't feel
committed enough to it
when you've decided to get to work
curiosity
uh
i always the way i begin to approach a
subject
i always try and think of key events
which
epitomize
uh
the period or the subject that i'm
writing about
um
for example in the face of battle i i
took three battles each which seemed to
me to epitomize a particular moment in
the development to warfare
and
i analyze the events in terms of always
in terms of a number of quite material
um
[Music]
factors one of these is uh geography
the location
what what what the the terrain was like
how the terrain
would have influenced the competence on
on each side
and another is which i think is
absolutely fundamental and i spend a
great deal of time with is what is
called the order of battle that's to say
making an exact list of who was involved
so that you it's a bit like doing
accounts in business
uh you know businessmen say that unless
the accounts are straight
uh
they
they cannot be certain that their
business is on
being conducted on sound lines
i always say that unless you've got an
exact order of battle and you know how
many
for example at
waterloo how many
uh french units there were and how many
british and allied units there were
on each side and they're exactly their
strength and their position and who who
commanded them that you you can't do the
account of the battle the literally the
account in both senses you can't do the
story of the battle and you can't do the
uh
the the bill correctly
so and it's only afterwards i think only
after that that i've done those things
that i
begin to think about the
more imaginative
uh less material aspects
in my hands are
about seven books that belong to john
keegan and i'm going to show you what
they look like fields of battle the wars
for north america
a history of warfare
the battle for history
war in our world
the book of war
these most of these are available i
guess through penguin
show books and still in print
most of them are a mask of command and
our calls from portland oregon go ahead
please yes yes i'm here go ahead john
am i on yes sir okay i have a question
for uh mr uh uh sir john keegan uh i
think it's a privilege i'm able to ask
this question uh i have some of his
books i read an interesting book
the myth of the great war by john moser
i don't know if you're familiar with it
but
his thesis in the book was
that
the the the sense of the german effort
in the
first world war was grossly underplayed
that they were winning much more
victories than was they were given
credit for they had superior artillery
they had superior tactics
their body counts in terms of uh the
kill of the allies was much higher and
they were always being downplayed by the
propaganda that was rife uh during that
period the first world war
do you give any credence to that or is
he just off on the left field here well
i know the book you mean
um
and i think his general argument has a
great deal in it uh the german army was
the most professional fighting force in
in the world in 1914 and
it kept up its level of professionalism
throughout the first world war
um
i think he then rather
mishandles his argument because
he attaches great importance well as a
as a sort of demonstration of of what he
means he he um
he does a great deal of analysis of
about the fighting for
a a mountainous position called the the
hartmann violence cop
down uh on the franco-german border near
switzerland known to the french levies
and he points out that time and again
the germans because they had
highly trained mountain troops
were much more successful in the french
at
contesting this high ground
but
in fact
mountain warfare is very very
specialized nobody's ever won a war by
superiority and mountain warfare and i
think he rather threw his argument away
by
moving from a good general point to
an interesting but rather unimportant
specialized point
sir john keegan's new book is called
intelligence in war in your bookstores
now we go to manhattan you're on the air
yes uh good afternoon hello hello i have
a two-part question i wanted you to
discuss your involvement in the
valentine violent history series
and its impact on
the latter development of your craft
and also i was interested in uh what war
movie was your favorite in a different
uh
area of media all right both very good
questions if i may say the valentine
series uh
um
began to appear i think in the in the
1960s
they were
there were about a hundred of them
um they were published in the us by
valentine books they were edited in
britain by a remarkable man called barry
pitt
um
the
the formula was well as far as the
author was concerned the formula was
standard
you had to write i think about
thirty to forty thousand words
for which
you were paid a flat fee of a thousand
dollars
now to somebody in his twenties
recently married with
babies
uh
in the in the in the court a thousand
dollars cash on the barrel seemed very
very
attractive indeed and barry
pitt got a whole lot of what were to be
in the future very well known writers to
take on these titles for valentine books
for example uh uh he got paul kennedy
um the
author of the rise and fall of the great
prize uh and a professor at yale was
then a
struggling young academic as i was to
join the team and numbers of other
who numbers other people who were to
become welded and serious writers were
struggling away for barry pitt uh
turning out these these short
uh
quick books
uh for cash the odd thing is that not
only was the formula attractive to the
writers it also produced rather good
books some of those valentine books
remain although considering the
conditions in which they were produced
they remain extremely good accounts for
the subjects they're devoted to and and
uh you're not the only person who
who reminds me that i was once a
valentine box author and i'm not
i'm delighted to acknowledge that i was
favorite war movie
um sorry favorite war movie my favorite
war movie
i'd
i've been that i don't think i'm the
only military historian would say so i
don't like war movies
las vegas nevada go ahead please hi how
are you doing today
i uh as many uh
wars and conflicts that you've studied
do you see any similarities in today's
quote-unquote conflict in iraq
um
what's going on in iraq is uh
it seems the newspapers
uh and it's more than newspapers than
the television really the newspapers
managed to make it look
gloomy
terrible
unprecedented etc i don't think it is i
think that
typically wars always end with a rather
mitty or typically
it it has been typical for for wars in
the past to have ended in a messy and
difficult way
the western outlook particularly in the
united states and britain
was wrongly affected by the end of the
the second world war both the first
world war and the second world war
particularly the second world war when
the germans and the japanese
suddenly laid down their arms on a
certain day they laid down their arms
and they gave no trouble thereafter
the the allies occupied their countries
uh overturned their governments brought
in new constitutions
um and
directed both
former competent states on into entirely
new paths and we think that was normal
in fact it was highly abnormal it's
about the only time in history that it's
ever happened i think you know end of
war
total end of resistance
and a new start
and the newspapers and to a certain
extent the television are
now arguing that that is what should
have happened in iraq but it would have
been most unusual if it had happened
and
this
continued scrappy resistance by
uh followers surviving followers of
saddam and by ex-members of the bat
party i think it's far more typical of
what usually happens at the end of the
war than
1945 was how much are you writing for
the daily telegraph of london
uh well i am on i'm on the start of the
daily telegraph i write whenever the
editor tells me to write in fact i of
course had a very great deal of work to
do um
during the gulf war since when he's been
rather kind and i haven't had to write
very much allen texas you're almost sir
john keegan good morning thank you for
taking my call a couple of the other
callers already took my question so
but i'm a great admirer of sir keegan
and i have to think i have all but just
one of his books which is i just put an
order in for yesterday so right very
nice of you oh
you're outstanding writer sir uh the um
this the scientist who uh recently had
committed suicide in great britain uh
you wrote an article about him
and comparing your own civil service
with his and i was wondering if you had
any comments
about the way the
inquiry played out after the fact
in light of that original article that
you wrote
well
it's a
difficult question to answer because
the death of this unfortunate scientist
who committed suicide peers appears to
have committed suicide his name uh kelly
dr david kelly
uh
is now the subject of a
high-level judicial inquiry
and the judge lord
hutton has not yet reported and won't
report
i think until early in the new year so
we we do not know what a judgment he
will come to
um
there's been there's been
endless speculation about why dr dr
kelly committed suicide
my my
view was that he was a career civil
servant
and
[Music]
because of as a result of his
involvement with the press
which was forbidden
or was
traditionally been forbidden to civil
servants he was threatened with
disciplinary action by the civil service
and got into a panic and committed
suicide but
this is rather an individual view of
mine others don't accept it others say
that it was the pressure that the media
put upon him or the pressure that
parliament put upon him that caused him
to take his own life um
we won't know what the official verdict
is until lord hutton reports i think it
will be accepted because lord hutton
has established himself as a figure of
great authority and trust
in british life by the way he's
conducted the inquiry so far
albuquerque new mexico you're almost sir
john keegan hello good morning hello
as a marine my main interest in in world
war ii is the pacific
and i recently finished reading fly boys
by brady i believe
i'm also interested in in what has
become called revisionist history and
i i'd like to ask a question about a
specific point uh specifically the
ending of the war
and with japan with the atomic bomb
and and some of the
controversy recently raised about
the necessity of doing that
i can't remember the book but i recently
remember
uh reading about an argument which
essentially said the revisionist
argument is that
the life of a combatant civilian
was more important than the lives of the
civilians that were being taken within
the
remnants of the greater east asia
prosperity sphere do you have any
comments on that
well i think i'd
i think i'd need to have the questions
qualified rather i i
i mean to who to whom were these lies
more important clearly the lives of
chinese civilians were not important to
the japanese high command uh
the japanese high command regarded china
simply as a a place from which
uh
japan's means of livelihood should be
extracted and right at the end of the
war in 1944
in particular they were conducting uh
what we call the rice offensives which
were fought to extend the area of
japanese occupation and
capture
uh
bigger areas of the uh of rice
rice production
taking rice from china
caused the death of millions of chinese
and the japanese didn't care about that
um
i would have thought that the the the
the american high command was uh um
was concerned about the lives of the
chinese they were after all the chinese
were our allies
um
but was less concerned about the lives
of japanese civilians who were
were being bombed by
by the us army air force as a means of
shortening japan's resistance
so i think it depends you know you have
to define who who you who was caring
about whom
or not you taught for 26 years at
sandhurst you've been defense
correspondent for the daily telegraph
since 86.
you often think conrad black in these
books who is the owner of the daily
telegraph and the jerusalem post and the
chicago sun times
but the question i have for you is he
just completed a 1200 page book on fdr
did he consult you at all
yes i i know i mean i'm in the old
position of being
what i like to think on on terms of good
friendship with
the proprietor of the newspaper of which
i'm an employee um
and i did in fact i have read and
annotated
portions of this enormous life of of
franklin delano roosevelt that
conrad black has written
which i think is awfully good conrad is
a most unusual newspaper proprietor in
that he's a genuine intellectual um i
don't think most newspaper proprietors
are intellectuals but conrad is he's
interested in ideas
and
uh he's also immensely knowledgeable
and one of the things that he's uh
really
knowledgeable about he's american
american not in case he's a canadian but
he's a he's a sort of but he's a member
of the house of lords and well he's he's
born a canadian he's become a british
citizen
he has residences in the united states
and he's a great expert on american
politics
and i must say the passages in his
life
of fdr about
uh new deal politics before the war and
about uh
fdr's wartime politics are absolutely
fascinating i think he deals he's
got a real understanding of how the
politics of that era worked sir john
keegan will be with us for two hours and
eight more minutes let's go to
providence rhode island you're on the
air
hi sir um hi i i have a question with
some background um the background is um
fema
fema is creating uh citizen camps uh
through ash ashcroft in america
the recent bid on these camps are um
three camps uh one million detention per
camp and um fort dix has um what many
consider slave labor camps um
there are secret detentions in america
and um and caller we're going to move on
uh let's go to los angeles you're on the
air los angeles
yeah i'd like to ask um
mr keegan if he's familiar with a book
called american soldiers also fought by
general bullock
i'm afraid i'm not no uh he he was uh
he commanded uh
i think he was a division commander
in world war one his general thesis was
that
the
french and the british were in fact
losing the word of the germans that kylo
and so
uh kind of begged wilson to come into
the war to bail them out and that after
the americans came in
they started winning some battles and
the british and and french then started
winning and they ultimately won the war
that the musargon was really kind of a
decisive battle in it
and then after the war then particularly
clem also denigrated the american effort
and general bullock was quite an angry
man about it well i i i think he had
reason to be um
the
the both the british and the french took
a rather patronizing attitude towards
this enormous army of
untrained soldiers
who appeared in france in 1917
the american
the american government and the american
armed forces and
by extraordinary efforts uh both of
intellect and organization
managed to uh
transform the
war situation
um
but the the the soldiers who crossed the
atlantic were not
it has to be said were not
well trained
uh
and the british the french less say the
british said
well
look you
give us
uh blocks
of these raw recruits of yours and we
will put them into our divisions into
our
formations and we will use them as
reinforcements and replacements and by
serving alongside our soldiers they will
learn how to
uh to fight uh the the america
particularly pershing the the american
expeditionary force commander said
absolutely not i am commanding a unified
american army under american command and
i am not having foreigners british or
french generals telling telling my
soldiers what to do and
he got his way
um and i think he was absolutely right
to do so uh it was a lot of proper role
for these americans to to serve as
replacements in foreign units and uh
the the the doughboys in fact lurked
tremendously quickly and they fought
with
amazing courage and eventually
remarkable efficiency as well
so
i'm on the side of pershing
before we went on the air you said you
were going to have to have your hips
replaced and the reason i bring it up is
because you always tell your readers
that since age 13 you've had a limp due
to
orthopedic tuberculosis that's right
which is what
oh well of course this horrible disease
has now largely disappeared
used to be a scourge of european and
american life um
uh
you could get it in the lungs with
consumption which uh and you could get
it in the bones uh
i got it in the in the bone and it um i
had to spend several years in hospital
as a result
and then i made a wonderful recovery and
for during my 20s and 30s and 40s and
50s i was fit as a flea and leapt about
the place and went all over the world
and went to wars and
i did all that sort of thing but in my
60s um
things started to catch up on me and i
began to
uh
limp very badly and to have difficulty
in getting about and now uh an
orthopedic surgeon has said well i'm you
know you've got to the stage where i
must
uh
insert
artificial hips
and a knee as well i think i have to
have three of these replacement
operations when
uh february i'm going to have the first
on february the 4th
when it's finished will you be able to
walk normally again i i'm he
she it's a lady she says that there's
every chance that i will be um
agile again
and i'm
i believe her sir john keegan we go to
cincinnati
good afternoon gentlemen hi
god bless c-span uh recently on the book
tv i guess it was about three or four
weeks ago i tuned in late in the evening
and a historian was on unfortunately his
name
i don't recall and he
he said that uh
america should never have entered the
world war one and had they remained
neutral the war would have entered and
ended in a stalemate eliminating any
possibility of hitler coming to power
first of all do you agree with that he
also said that
britain maintained a c embargo of
germany for seven months after the end
of world war one resulting in the
starvation of thousands of german
citizens uh is or either of those uh how
do you agree with the first point and is
the second point true thank you uh thank
you very much i got the second point i
didn't get the first point
who did he say shouldn't have entered
the first world war oh
he's not on the line any longer i'm
sorry i missed the point all right how
about the second point the second point
i
indeed
you can't disagree with it that the
british
uh it is largely the british not the
french did maintain did sustain the
blockade of germany uh after the germans
had entered into the armistice
um
specifically precisely to force them to
sign
and this
was a matter of this was caused great
bitterness in germany they said
we
accepted wilson's 14 points
we've laid down our arms we are ready to
make peace but it should be a just an
honorable piece
and not one dictated to us imposed on us
by further
coercion by depriving our women and
children of food and effectively
starving us to the to to the peace
peace treaty table
and
it was the the the policy of sustaining
the blockade was a cause of very very
great britain it's in germany
uh throughout the 20s and into the 30s
and and fed hitler's propaganda
is
is there a college or university or a
west point or something like that where
your books are now required reading
oh i think quite a lot i mean students i
meet in england tell me that
uh
my books are on their reading list and i
think they are in the united states as
well have you ever told uh totaled up
the number of books that are sold with
all the backlist and everything in a
year's time in this country
no i would like to know i'm always
wondering quite how many books i have
sold so you just get the check they
don't tell you how many you sold
no i
i it's something that's on my list of
things to do
to find out how many books i have sold
wheatland wyoming go ahead please yes um
in america we hear a lot about d-day and
the battle of the bulge
but uh how did that compare with the
scale of the
battle on the eastern front and did we
face the same caliber of
soldier and equipment that the russians
did since uh 1941
well that's a very
important question
um
i think that we
uh
uh
until night until d-day until june 1944
hitler always deployed
both the best
both the bulk of his armies and the best
of his armies against the russians
uh and on the other front say in italy
and in in north africa
um
the numbers were fewer and the number of
elite formations was fewer also however
after june 1944 when he had to fight the
allies on the mainland continent of
europe
uh
increasingly it was the americans and
the british who found themselves up
against the
the best of the german
formations not equal numbers but um a
disproportionate number of hitler's
armored divisions panzer divisions
because
uh the americans of the british were
mechanized to a degree that the russians
were not and in a way hitler had to send
his tanks to fight the british and
americans if he was going to stave off
an early disaster
um
but i know what you're getting at and
that you're right to do so which is that
uh the heaviest of the fighting
consistently
the heaviest of the fighting was on the
eastern front rather than on the western
front but that is not to say that some
of the battles on the western front were
not as
uh extreme as some of those fought on
the on the eastern front a couple more
books from sir john keegan the price of
admiralty back 1988 out by penguin still
available who's who in the military
history from about 1996 i believe
co-authored with andrew wheatcroft
1453 to the present day
we go to uh illyria ohio next good
afternoon thank you hello good afternoon
sir keegan has a great mind
on the background of studies in war and
leaders would he have a sense of where
saddam might be now
because i have sensed right along that
he left iraq
when the bombing started and could very
well be in a place i would say like
berlin would he have any comment on that
well
if i knew where saddam was i think that
i would be
my i'd be very much sought after by the
western intelligence organizations i
don't know where saddam is
it's widely felt
within the coalition forces in in iraq
that he's still
somewhere
in the what's called the sunni triangle
north of uh
north west and north of uh
baghdad around his old
home area of tikrit
and it's being passed from place to
place
often
moving every few hours
and i think that's perfectly possible um
the
the people who are causing the trouble
uh are clearly
acting under inspiration i think
and it's most likely that they are in
contact with saddam so maybe he's still
inside iraq
if not
it's difficult to know where he could
have gone because i don't think any
government wishes to be identified
take the risk of being identified
as hiding saddam or even
um
providing the territory on which he
which he is hiding
so
the theory is for example it's been said
that he might be in yemen or
in somalia
um
they're they're all
they all have difficulties about them as
explanations
um experts say that saddam is extremely
careful of his own safety and therefore
it's most unlikely that he's gone to
such a lawless country as somalia where
every man's hands so easily turns
against others and where he might easily
get murdered
i don't know is the answer i simply
don't know
if i had to
put money down i'd guess that he's still
somewhere in iraq but i can't guess any
better than that
the woman that called from illyria ohio
is the first woman to call out of 15
callers during this first hour
does that surprise you and you have any
idea how many women buy your books
no it doesn't surprise me because war is
a masculine subject not a feminine
subject it it
often in fact usually does surprise me
that i have women readers although i
know i have women readings and when i
give lectures i'm always
both surprised but
pleased
to find women in the audience asking me
questions and women very often ask the
most perceptive questions
woodland hills california good morning
to you good morning further to the
occupation of germany and japan
do you think that the degree of
destruction sustained by both countries
had something to do with the population
being resigned to defeat
and if so would this support an argument
against negotiated settlements
in the whole
i i i i think it undoubtedly did
but to say it was the chief factor
in uh
bringing them to
accept defeat resign themselves to
defeat and uh uh
adopt
a post-war stance of total
non-resistance which they did i think
they'd had such a terrible time
uh
under bombing that they they
simply
relieved that it was over and they did
not wish anything to
uh
they didn't wish to help with anything
that might start uh such violence up
again
um after all
the british and americans
had um
destroyed
uh
almost every the center of every major
city in germany had been destroyed by
bombing by 1945.
in in japan
a hundred of the
major urban areas in japan had been
completely obliterated by american
bombing mainly incendiary bombing
appalling damage had been done by
by
what's known as conventional bombing
quite apart from the from the atomic
bombs and it's it's just not the least
bit surprising that the germans and the
japanese people
wanted to give in
how old are your four children
my they are 41
uh 40 and twins of 38.
and how many of them are here in the
united states working
none they're all in england although my
elder daughter who is 41
is married to
uh
an american he's now become a british
citizen but he was he's a new yorker
how many of them are writing for a
living
none of them are writers one is a
scientist that's my eldest son he's a
scientist at oxford
my younger daughter is an actress rather
a successful actress my younger son is a
is a journalist but he's a
uh an editor rather than a writing
journalist and uh
my
41 year elder daughter was a journalist
and a writing journalist but she
subsequently had five children so has
has her hands full otherwise
well the last time we talked was 10
years ago and a lot's happened in those
10 years let's go to buffalo new york
you're on the air
uh first of all brian thank you thank
you cispan thank you for your treat uh
mr keegan i'm also a non-service
historian right
my question concerns american canola
i'm nervous i'm sorry colonial uh
liberation yes uh do you think
the american colonies were liberated
and that came about directly because of
the french intervention at all with
spain and the dutch and
etcetera which
in fact left the colonies as an open
soar in itself which became a book of
history
well it's a it's a very good question
but it's very big question
um i think that uh
uh
washington and his confederates had uh
uh
done a pretty good job in
in
bringing the british armies in north
america to a standstill
uh but the the the the the actual the
thing that precipitated the surrender at
yorktown was undoubtedly the
intervention of the french and american
fleets
and their winning of the battle of the
virginia capes in 1781 just before the
surrender at yorktown
um
it was
one of the few times in the 18th century
when the royal navy was clearly defeated
uh by an enemy fleet and
um
it persuaded the high command the
british high command
that uh
the army
the the the british army at yorktown
couldn't
safely be supported any longer and
would probably all probably ought to
seek terms from the americans and say
that's what happened
we have some video from your home where
you do your writing in wilshire
england and we're going to have it on
the screen right there you can see it
where is this located
it's about 25 miles south of bath
which uh that beautiful georgian city
which so many uh
americans visit when they're in england
it's about
30 miles west of salisbury the great
cathedral city where which again so many
americans also visit
um it's in the depths of the country
we're walking up the steps and our
cameras
outside the room where you're right i'm
getting we're going upstairs to my
to my study now how much time do you
spend in this room
about
10 hours a day eight hours a day at
least
it's where i
uh i sit at my desk and uh
uh
with a pen in my hand sometimes the pen
isn't moving across the paper but quite
often it is there's one of your books
the history award from one of my books
um and you are you still writing with
the long hair yes i am because
uh i find it quicker
not to write articles but to write books
i find it quicker to use a pen
because you can use your other hand to
to deal with other you know with
paperwork and look through looking
things up that's your view out the
window there that's the view out of my
window down the garden
view out to saul's replay and i look out
towards a
uh
an iron age
uh hill fort
uh
where
the former inhabitants of this bit of
countryside
shut themselves off from their enemies
about 2 000 years ago
there's some bronze aid fortification
too
four thousand years old do you get
writer's block anymore at any time
as soon as i start
as soon as i i think you know i try and
think of
some way of starting each morning and
as soon as i do the pen flows pretty
pretty
steadily over the paper how many hours
can you write straight through without
stopping
um
maybe five hours i think oh well i will
stop i'll i'll get up and
have a walk about or i'll go get myself
a drink or something or other but uh are
you working on another book now yes i'm
writing a book about the war in iraq
who's the lady on the screen and that is
lindsay my secretary who my assistant
who can turn my handwriting into the
most beautiful typewriting and and she
said she's so nervous she's a a master
um
a master interpreter what's the cat's
name
i didn't see which one that was black
think it was oscar oscar is a very
dangerous cat he bit me once and nearly
took the top off one of my fingers so um
we have two other cats which are
american cats maine coons which are
delightful oscar is an english farm cat
and very dangerous
now your wife is a writer is she still
writing she's a biographer she's uh
written biographies of
alma mala who is married to gustav
mahler the and then also married to
walter gropius and um
[Music]
uh sorry the names escapes me at the
moment um
and then she wrote a life of oscar
koshka the painter santa barbara
california thanks for waiting go ahead
please
yes i am writing the novel actually a
novel series and starts in world war one
one of the questions which i have is uh
was there ever a battle in world war one
where british and american forces fought
side by side and literally came in
contact with each other
and was the battle of soy sands one of
those battles
do you know that that is too technical a
question for me to answer i'm sorry i
can't i can't help you with your novel i
i i apologize potomac maryland you're on
the air i'm afraid i may have another
technical question for you all right um
it's in particular it's with regard to
another military historian trevor dupoy
yes indeed now he uh in the 1970s he
created
a quantified judgment method of analysis
of historical combat data yes which is a
fancy way of saying
he went into various battles and studied
them and then out of them created combat
efficiency
values that's right down to the soldier
individual soldier level yes and my
question for you is
do you find uh his work in this area to
be would you consider it to be valid
now let me say it right at the start
that i'm a tremendous admirer of the
dupuis there are two of them father and
son
and uh
i think their chief work their great
work is their encyclopedia of military
history uh which
i i'm on my second copy i i
i've used it so much the first one wore
out
it's about 1100 pages
and it is a i think a total compendium
of
the wars of the world from the beginning
of time to the present day uh in every
part of the world and every country it's
an absolutely extraordinary book and
indispensable uh having said that i let
me say that i don't
follow
dupuis senior in this
uh attempt to reduce
human
performance in combat to
a formula i just think it's too
difficult i think there are too many too
many factors
this was first published in 1979 and
it's huge uh what is it called world
armies well done is i had the idea
that um it would be useful
and profitable to to produce a reference
book about all the armies of the world
because it was at a time
uh towards the end of the cold war when
armies were
uh
very important
agents of
disturbance and change in world affairs
and i i simply thought that there were
many many people from journalists to
politicians who would need such a
reference book and i debated a great
deal of time to it
and i enlisted the help of many
colleagues and we did in fact produce
nobody's ever done anything else like it
it's unique
but it was not unfortunate it was
the idea was that it should become an
annual publication in fact it was only
published
in two editions and so my idea did not
succeed but i continued to think that it
was a good one manhattan go ahead please
hello
hello hi it's an honor to be speaking
with you sir
i have a general question about the
ottoman military oh yes i have in fact
dreamed of being able to hear your views
on it i hope you won't find it too
generous
the ottomans is one of the most
important military people in history
that's uh
i i will uh
phrase it in two related questions first
uh
were there any aspects that
distinguished the ottoman military in
your opinion from the european in some
basic way
and secondly i would like to hear your
views on
whether you see certain things in its
organization and character perhaps that
even in its glory days could be
identified as precursors of decline
yes the first part of your question is
easier to answer than the second
um
the
um the ottomans
were uh an absolutely extraordinary
military people and uh
i suppose
unique in their time
um
or
although i don't see how you could have
replicated their military organization
elsewhere because
it depended upon the power of both the
power of religion and the absolute power
of the ottoman sultan as ruler
um
he
the the ottoman sultan was also khalif
he was the head of the faithful
and
all
sunni muslims were supposed to follow
his authority they will well um shia
muslims too but they didn't uh recognize
him as khalif um
so he had so he had a a religious
element to his leadership he also has as
sultan and the most powerful ruler in
the world uh
in
with the exception perhaps to the
emperor of china uh he had uh
uh power beyond beyond that of any
christian
king
and he used it to create a very
extraordinary army in which the
most important elements were actually
slaves
it sounds odd and it was odd but they
were recruited from the horse peoples of
the of central asia as boys and they
were trained
uh in military arts
in
in constantinople in istanbul and they
then became the military slaves of the
the sultan
with enormous privileges so there was
this was reconciled the
the sort of anomaly of slaves having
military power they were they were
slaves but they enjoyed tremendous
privileges
and they also fought with incredible
tenacity they
the europeans
i think the the christians of the 15th
and 16th century i often
think believe that they were confronted
by the power of the devil when they met
when they met the ottomans
they fought with such
disregard for for their own safety with
such and with such pitiless cruelty but
anyhow in their heyday which went on
[Music]
well from the
14th century a.d to the
beginning of the 18th century the the
ottomans were
almost literally unstoppable
honolulu go ahead please
uh yes i'd like to say this is a
pleasure to talk to uh with john
keegan sergio excuse me and i've seen
him many times on uh television
i just found something out i heard a
reference made to this and i don't know
if it's true that in fact the germans
did scuttle their own ships after world
war one
and that was the greatest act of uh uh
self-destruction of military
self-destruction i don't know if that's
true and i would like his comments on
that
and secondly i would like to wish him
well on his operations i know people who
have had both of those operations one of
them was a wine producer i had it uh
when i saw he was playing tennis at 80.
so
tennis might be a good cure for that my
sister has her hip replacement and she's
jogging now so
good luck but i'd like to hear that
answer about the i think herd was
scuttled at scott the flow and i'd like
uh sir john's comments on that thank you
well it's very very kind of you to wish
me well and i'm encouraged by
by these uh uh
this news of uh your sister and others
um about the sh about the scuttling yes
of course
um
the the british had taken the the german
battle fleet
up to its own
uh
battlefield anchorage in the north of
scotland at scapa flow uh at the end of
the war that was one of the conditions
of the armistice that the germans should
send their major ships up to scarpa
flair or should could hand them over to
the british
uh but they
were left with their own crews aboard
and
when it became clear and this we've
discussed earlier on the program when it
became clear that the allies were going
to impose
their own terms on the germans by
sustaining the blockade
it was decided
within the fleet
within the german fleet at scapaflow
that they wouldn't allow the british to
get possession of their ships so they
opened uh the seacocks
let let the sea in and the ships all
settled on the bottom um it was
the most sensational world new
world news
um
and um
there they remained
for some of them are still there but
there was a great salvage operation in
the 20s and 30s to get them up again but
they were ruined as ships and they
simply went to be broken up i have a
question here from assistant professor
of criminal justice peter puglio
of the william rainey harper college in
palatine illinois
if you had the power to make one or two
history books required reading for every
citizen in the united states what books
would you choose please be as specific
as possible gosh
i almost require notice of that question
well first of all let me ask you about
your own books which one if you could
choose one of those or two of those that
everybody should read which would they
be
well i think that other people would
choose the face of battle
and i do have to say
that the face of battle is a is a very
good read it it continues to
you know it you can pick it up and
it flows along
uh
the book
the book into which i put
more of myself than any other book i
really really worked at it and it was a
great effort on on my part was a history
of warfare now history of warfare
history of the history of warfare yes
now what about others other books if you
if you had to recommend um
well you know
people historians have funny tastes
uh one of my favorites
i don't think it would do a lot for
other people but it did an enormous
amount for me a funny little book called
gunpowder and galleys by my friend john
gulmartian who used to be a professor at
the
uh u.s air force
academy at colorado springs
and it's an account of
galley warfare in the mediterranean in
the 16th century but it's also
uh
a general analysis of the nature of
naval warfare and it's also
a very acute analysis of the cultural uh
elements in warfare between christians
and muslims it's therefore of tremendous
relevance to the present moment name
again will martin gilmart in
r t g-u-i-l-m-a-r-t-i n
john gulmartin usually known as joe will
martin ex-colonel
united states air force name of the book
gunpowder
and galleys sanford north carolina thank
you for waiting go ahead please uh yes
sir i've i read your face of battle and
mask of command both required reading at
uh at west point
and my question is uh following the us
military victory in iraq and the ongoing
nation-building struggle has the faith
of battle dramatically changed and what
type of leader is required for victory
yes i do think the face of battle has
changed
one of the reasons being the nature of
modern small arms
uh
one of the things i think the most horri
that most horrifies us about
war today is that
high-minded well-trained
uh
western soldiers
uh who've been instructed in the laws of
war and in the proper behavior
uh of
the the the legitimate defenders of
their countries
come up against child soldiers they come
up against eleven-year-olds
uh
who
have un undeveloped consciences
uh after all what does what does a child
know about the sanctity of human life or
about the rule of law or by any of those
things which an adult raised in the
proper military training system does
know about
and
this child has a kalashnikov
and with a kalashnikov
he can kill
50 people
in a few seconds and what's awful is
that
sometimes these child soldiers do kill
50 people in a few seconds
in these awful episodes in african civil
war for example in the
in the war between the hutsies and
and the tutsi hutus on the tutsi we did
have massacres of this sort
and
the
extravagance of modern firepower makes
many of the ideas i advanced in the face
of battle irrelevant redundant the
warfare isn't
uh
a
a a small
unformed human being
can
overcome
uh
a much
more responsible and more highly trained
human being and
all the qualities which
the
the the legitimate soldier deploys are
are
they're wiped out
by
this transformation in in the uh in the
nature of firepower
we're at the halfway point our guest is
sir john keegan he lives in great
britain has spent
how much time in the united states any
way to quantify i know you're at
princeton in 84
you came here for six months and 57
yes i've well i've
three times lived for quite long periods
of the united states i've been as you
say i came here on a traveling
scholarship
in 1957
mainly visiting the south
and visited most of the civil war
battlefields
84 i was a fellow of princeton and 97 i
was a professor at vassa
and besides that i visited the united
states dozens and dozens of times and
been
to many of the uh
well many of the lower 48 i have also
been to hawaii so i've been outside the
lower 48 as well in one of your books
you said you've been to 32 of the first
year
i counted up
um i think i've been to
between 30 and 40 of the states
but i'd like to say since you give me
the opportunity that i'm
a tremendous admirer of of
the united states and of americans and
of america and um
uh i never
miss an opportunity in my own country
uh of saying so i i believe i i'm deeply
grateful
in my own life for what
uh america has done for me personally
and for my country portland oregon
you're on
yeah thank you for taking my call i
was curious to keep going on the idea of
what the legitimate soldier was
uh
the united states has had a history of
funding terrorist organizations like al
qaeda particularly
in the uh late 1970s to draw the soviets
into afghanistan
and supplied
textbooks through the university of
nebraska spent about 40 million dollars
to teach young children jihad
and i'm wondering
what your take is on that and also what
your opinion is on the current uh
use of or proposed use of developing
tactical nuclear weapons
well i think i need more information
about your first point i i i it's i'm
unfamiliar with it i don't think that
the
uh i've never heard the united states
government uh
uh encouraging illegal or improper
behavior in institutions of public
education
what i meant by a legitimate uh
soldiers is somebody raised within
the sort of training system that you
have in this country and in my own
country where soldiers uh
very clearly instructed
in their duties and in uh uh
and in the the proprieties of
the legalities of warfare where they are
taught the difference between a legal
command and an illegal command where
they talked about the difference between
proper conduct and improper conduct and
i i that is i think soldiers in the in
the united states army and in the
british army
by the time they've completed their
training know
uh when they are allowed to use their
weapons and when they are not allowed to
use their weapons and that is really
that is what makes a legitimate soldier
shreveport louisiana you're next uh good
afternoon brian
i have a couple of questions for sir
john and i'm so pleased that you have
him on your program today
uh one has to do with the great war
and the other of course with world war
ii
but uh
my uh thought is that uh
you know we hear about world war one as
being fought mainly on
the continent of europe and the trenches
of france
but uh
i'd like to hear sir john comment on the
fact that it was fought in many other
places throughout the world
three other three continents probably
and
about world war ii
i wonder about the continuing animosity
of the french government and the french
maybe
against english-speaking peoples and
whether churchill's act of uh
sinking the french navy
after the vici government
was set up
when the defeat of france took place in
world war ii
and i'd like to make one other comment
if i made brian about you personally
we're so glad to have had you here in
shreveport a couple of years ago and now
that we can call you and you may recall
you and i had
a private conversation about a grandson
of mine who was quite taken with c-span
in the presidential series
that you read
but anyway
we're happy that brian
was honored us from centenary college
and receive an honorary doctorate degree
thank you very much i sure enjoyed my
trip to shreveport
thank you um
two very interesting points of course
you're quite right about the world
nature of world war one
uh it wasn't just forty in france and
belgium
uh there was an important front in italy
too and the italians
uh
i think one of the reasons why the
italians did so badly in the second
world war was because they had exhausted
themselves of the first world war they
had suffered appalling casualties over
half a million dead
fighting the austrians and the germans
mainly up in the mountains of uh
what's now modern yugoslavia and uh
northern italy
um
it was fought on the eastern fort in
russia
on a very large scale uh in the front
that existed uh
in the caucasus right ran
down into the caucasus
uh and
there were sporadic campaigns in russian
central asia as well it's also fought in
africa there was a
very very skillful german guerrilla
leader called
von letoff four because
leads the the the british and the french
and the belgians and others a merry
dance all over east africa it was 40 in
the german west african colonies it was
fought in the pacific
where the germans conducted a cruiser
warfare campaign in 1914
um
and
there was even fighting on the mainland
of china where the
uh the japanese and the british
extinguished the german naval base at
singh tao so it was a genuine world war
about
why the french take this
hostile attitude to the english-speaking
peoples i i don't think it actually had
too much to do with the sinking of the
french fleet and masel kabir it caused
that caused a lot of bitterness at the
time but it was soon forgotten
i think it has more to do with the fact
that
uh
the french have never really recovered
from what they call
the terrible year
uh la terrible of 1940
where they were humiliated as a state
and a people
and
for all that the girl tried to do you
know he tried he argued
after
august 1944 that the french had
liberated themselves
a reference to the role of the
resistance uh
it was
it was too exaggerated a statement
i don't think he believed it and i don't
think the french believed it the french
knew that they had been liberated by the
americans from the british and they
could not forgive
the french the the americans and the
british for having done something which
they knew should never have been
necessary that the
france should not have been defeated in
1940 it should have uh been able to
defend itself it wasn't
and it was a humiliation to have that
terrible mistake retrieved by
people from across the sea and that is
at the root of this hostility the french
have for the english-speaking people
fountain valley california for sir john
keegan
hello
yes um
i am
presently working on a poem
about the american civil war
that is
about the
the um
uh
the vicksburg campaign yes
uh
primarily i'm interested in the in the
civil war the english civil war the
american civil war
uh as the uh
really as these
the history the story
uh
in my poem
of the american problem of the american
uh the making of america as homer
uh
made the story uh of the for the for the
uh
the uh unity of the greek states sure
yes uh as virgil justified caesar
in making the
roman empire which is which in fact he
did because the greatness of rome didn't
happen until
after caesar
decided to
to unify
the uh greatly
disparate uh the roman
colonies right
nobody seems to understand
when i say this
actually my discovery i'm interested in
civil war right and nobody seems to
understand the difference between civil
war the only person who i have read that
understands ironically what
ironically what understands the nature
between the two
was a gentleman named fuller
the historian fuller
who said that um
it wasn't lead it was the great general
of the civil war it was grant
i'm going to let you go you're into some
detail here yes i think
let me let me try and i i think it's a
very interesting enterprise of yours
of course the the american civil war did
produce
uh
some of the greatest of american poetry
through the work of walt whitman i find
whitman
uh on
the personal experience of
the civil war deeply deeply moving
he was a dresser he worked as a as a
medical assistant in
in hospitals he saw
suffering at
first hand
and he knew what suffering meant both to
the wounded
man and to their families and
i i'm unable ever to read to come up
from the fields rather without
feeling the onset of tears i think it's
a
a poem which
anybody who thinks or writes about war
shouldn't know more or less by heart
because it does
does
convey in
20 or 30 lines
exactly how agonizing it is
more so for those who stay behind than
for those who go to war
got an email here and i want to read it
carefully because it's complicated and
it has to do with the earlier topic
we're talking about and a lot of people
may not know what it is in the audience
this is from a man named rick
seikai or sakai
s-a-k-a-i
he asked me please don't let the record
stand as is
does your guest really want the last
word on the irving controversy to be
that quote deborah lips lipstick
is boring and irving is not unquote that
is embarrassingly superficial even
infantile and i can't believe that mr
keegan would like to leave the matter at
that
what about the substance who was right
then he says
one need not be overly delicate and
tentative irving himself has no problem
making clear that he is
a holocaust denier and an anti-semite he
has always made himself available to
appreciate
anti-semitic groups
yes i do wish i could have kept off the
irving case i
tried hard not to appear in court
um
i regarded my opinion of
of
irving's book hitler's war as a more or
less as a private one
um and i did very very much didn't want
to be associated publicly with irving
because i knew that public association
with irving only leads to trouble and
that email is a perfect example of why
it only leads to trouble because
it is not possible to
frame remarks about irving in a way
which
uh
reasoned remarks in a way which doesn't
give offence to particular
zionists or uh
philosophers or whatever one likes to
call them
but still i
stand by my judgment that
irving is a very interesting writer and
that his book hitler's war is a very
important book and i
equally stand by my judgment that all
all
lipstick said was that
um
irving has
unpleasant on our indefensible positions
but we all agree with that everybody
knows that to be the case i know it to
be the case i regard most of a lot of i
regard a lot of irving's
opinions as reprehensible but i'm simply
because i regard
some of his opinions many of his
opinions is reprehensible i am not going
to say that he is a bad historian
because he is not a bad historian he is
a very good historian who happens to
have some repugnant views
that's all pompano beach florida you're
almost sir john keegan hello
hello mr keegan hello
um i have a manuscript written by my
father about his experiences in the
first world war 1914 to
he wrote it in 1935
he saw the second world war coming
and he refers to don't let it happen my
question to you is this
some uh something that is this something
that people would still be interested in
hearing if so would it be better to be
published in scotland
versus usa
well um
i'm delighted to uh hear
your familiar accent and i suspect that
your father if he fought in the first
world war probably fought in
a regiment like the black watch or the
the gordon highlanders
it's difficult to give advice about
personal manuscripts without seeing them
there's certainly
a
a great interest still in the first
world war in scotland and i suspect if
you want to make a start that you should
uh
perhaps send it to the scottish national
war museum in edinburgh
chatsworth california hello
good morning thank you hello
first i would like to thank both brian
and sir john for all the good things
that they have brought to us and i am
certainly
well
versed in the writings that sir john has
made and i appreciate them
second i would like to mention to sir
john that last year i had a knee
operation and a year later i am in very
good shape and i
am
looking forward to his
experiencing the same recovery as i did
oh good
a question on that why did you wait so
long to have this operation oh
because
as i think often happens with um
what's effectively a degenerative
condition
you'll find for a long time
and then suddenly you start to get worse
quite quickly you know and indeed i can
feel myself getting worse
almost by the week
um
when i i mean when i was at vassar in
1997 which is only six years ago i was
still able to travel easily all over the
united states
now i travel with difficulties
tampa florida good afternoon
thank you very much i have two questions
first
sir john spoke earlier about the ottoman
uh i believe the honors aries their uh
military slave infantry troops and how
they were so effective for about 200
years particularly against the west
now as i understand it victor david
hanson another military historian
has his thesis is that the west almost
uniformly
bests the
eastern
forces because of western discipline
western organization and so forth is the
success of the ottomans and possibly
the earlier the mongols doesn't that's
that seems to me to contradict that
thesis
that the west uniformly does not always
triumph over eastern forces by virtue of
western organization western tactics and
so forth
well i that's a very perceptive point
and
may i thank you for mentioning the name
of victor davis hanson who
is
an american
uh historian in the ancient world he's a
professor at
the university of california
and
although i've never met him i regard him
as a close friend because we've written
to each other a great deal
victor davis is i think
absolutely right about uh
the
the nature of the difference between
western military culture and asiatic
asian military culture
whether it was mongol or whether it was
um
ottoman
it
stemmed from their extraordinary mastery
of the horse
particularly the small
uh step pony ridden without saddle or
stirrups
um
the the the the mongols on the turks
simply
they were they were almost part of their
horses
um and because they
because they were brought up
in the saddle lived on the step
uh
lived
very hard and frugal lives
they
there was little difference for them
between
being at peace and being at war
their life was equally hard either way
and
that
meant that the westerners found them
very very difficult to to
get the better off
it was only eventually when the west
had developed superior systems of
drill
and discipline
that they found a means of
breaking
well it was by then ottoman power it
wasn't so much weapons
the ottomans had equivalent weapons
but
by the time the allies i'm sorry by the
time the the west had uh
mastered the modern technique of drill
uh they did have a secret which the
the the horse peoples of the step
couldn't match
first there was um
in 1998 there was this book
the the smaller one of the two here the
first world war and then in 2001
underneath it
is this rather large much larger
illustrated version of the first world
war book by you um
how does this one do the big one 50
compared to the smaller one well i think
it's so very well i believe
the the publishers
cannot find
my publishers hutchinson in england
um
wanted to
the first world war had sold very well
so they thought they'd do an illustrated
version which meant
reducing the text from two hundred
thousand words to
under a hundred thousand words
uh which effectively meant completely
rewriting it
and also writing
um
40 or 50 000 words of long captions
because the all the illustrations had to
be explained so it was a considerable
labor but i greatly enjoyed it i i
i don't remember
the
the producing the the illustrated
history of the first world war was
really an effort i i
seem to go very easily
we have a little bit uh more than two
hours one hour to go with our guest sir
john keegan we go to oakland california
you're on the air
uh yes uh brian thank you so much for
uh giving such literature television uh
my question for sir john is the
following um
the joy of speaking with an expert and a
historian uh is to be able to give
perspective to conflict
the conflict that i would like his
opinion on specifically is a the
current war going on in israel between
israel and the palestinians
and i'm just wondering uh
does he see any particular parallel to
that that conflict and the conflict that
the british engaged both in first
in south africa with the boer war
and is there any parallel to
uh
british experience in india
ah well i think
i think i'll
say at once that there's no parallel
with the british experience in india
because apart from the indian mutiny of
1857 which was
a very particular sort of
conflict and not a conflict with between
an army and a people with a conflict
between two armies
uh i don't think i don't think india has
i don't think that you can make any
comparison at all between india and the
conflict in israel in the conflict
conflict in in south africa between the
british and the boers
i don't
really think that the
uh
the
israeli-palestinian conflict is
comparable with the british poor
conflict in south africa because
uh the whole problem in palestine or in
israel is whether the palestinians are
to have a state or not whereas in in
south africa in 1999 when the war
between the british and the boers broke
out the boers had two
internationally recognized states of
their own the orange free state and the
and the transfer republic they were they
were legitimate
uh their governments were legitimate
sovereign governments uh which actually
attacked
uh the british colonies of natalin and
uh cape province
uh
uh the war that resulted was a war
between the british empire
and these two small boar republics
transferal and lawrence free state which
the the boers gradually lost
but
my goodness they gave the british a
difficult time until they were
eventually overcome they they carried on
the war by the by regular means or
irregular means for three years what's
happening in israel is of course
entirely different and absolutely nobody
i think i think there is many opinions
about israel and palestine as there are
individuals of the world so whatever i
say would be
one opinion among hundreds and hundreds
of thousands
uh however
i i don't think i don't think it would
be generally
contested that it the whole issue is
whether
the palestinians should be allowed to
have a state of their own
and whether the israelis are justified
in denying the mistake
um
anyhow
contesting that issue is painful and
bloody and creates great anguish both
in the wider world and in israel and in
palestine and
it would be foolish to say where once
where one's sympathies where one's
sympathies lie
and very difficult very difficult indeed
to say where sympathies lie i was
brought up in the second world war
um
from an early age i
was aware as i did as i think any
any european must have been of the
appalling experience of the jews under
the nazis uh
that had
inevitably a very strong formative
influence on my outlook
uh on the world on the other hand one's
extremely aware of the
sense of injustice that the palestinians
have and one knows the reasons for it
and i think you need to
to say more than that is only to incite
controversy and not to
not to
palliate it
kirksville missouri you're next
oh yes sir john kagan
hello yes uh first of all i appreciate
all your books i love them all
and i have a quick question for you what
do you consider as the three or four
most crucial mistakes of hitler during
world war ii would it be uh like dunkirk
stalingrad kursk or not concentrating
the panzer divisions on the three
beaches that would have supported an
allied landing
ah
well i um
i i didn't i didn't quite hear whose
mistake it was i think you said hitler's
mistakes um if if if that is what you
said
um
i think hitler's real mistake
if he wanted to win was not to have
uh
organized planned and organized his his
scientific program better than he did
germany made was enormously successful
in the
development of critical military
technology between um well 1936 saying
and 1944 by 1944 the germans had the
following technological achievements to
their credit they had
built and flown the first helicopter
they had built and flow in the first jet
aircraft
and they had built and flown the first
cruise missile and they had built and
flown the first extra atmospheric
missile the v2
but
all these weapons were either not fully
developed or but
came too late into production
secondly
hitler had made
very very slow progress with the
development of nuclear weapons he had
made some progress
but not enough partly because
of his persecution of jewish scientists
which meant that the talent which might
have been available to him had gone
abroad had fled abroad in most cases
uh and uh secondly because he
was parsimonious with the money and
spent it inefficiently there were i
think 12 separate agencies who were
supposed to be developing nuclear
weapons in nazi germany and as a result
none of them got enough support and none
of them got enough money
had he
developed a nuclear weapon and
had either the cruise missile the v1 or
the
the rocket the v2 in production early
enough he would have won the wall
he would have bombarded london he would
have bombarded the the invasion ports
the d-day couldn't have taken place
he would have
destroyed the american armies in britain
having done so
he could have dictated his own terms
eventually i suppose
the americans would have uh
uh brought their own nuclear weapons to
to uh
the
the practical stage as they did indeed
in 1945 and there would probably have
been a counter bombardment of europe
with nuclear weapons by the americans
but
uh that would have been too late hitler
would have
would have frustrated
the allies efforts to win the war by
conventional means
sir john keegan's current book is
intelligence and war knowledge of the
enemy from napoleon to al-qaeda
it's in your bookstores and just
last year john keegan on winston
churchill one of the penguin
lives
series and our next call is moab utah
you're on the air
hello hello
oh
i wanted to i wanted to speak to
suggested john i am yeah yes hello i was
um
uh for several years uh i was secretary
to major alexander de soversky when i
lived in new york yes perhaps i've heard
of him of course he was uh he was uh
a pioneer of uh airpower yes rather and
i was
i'm an ex-wife actually right
well in his book
america too young to die he made two
statements that i've never been i've
never heard commented on at any time and
one of them
as as follows
he claimed that
president truman
was more or less forced by
general george marshall
to authorize the bombing of um
uh hiroshima and nagasaki because
general marshall was insistent
that the american troops should land in
japan
you know with swords waving and so forth
and uh and sort of take over that way
and truman realizes the tremendous loss
of american life and therefore he
authorized the bombing of the as you
know that's one statement the other one
is that after the war
major disappears he had an interview
with the emperor of japan
in which the emperor said to him
but why did you refuse several times to
accept our surrender
those two statements i would
very much appreciate your opinion about
sir john
well thank you um
of course i remember seversky
as
a small boy because he his connection
with a film which i think many
uh cinema guys
uh saw in 1942 or 43
called victory through air power which i
think was either
written by or written in cooperation
with uh
with colonel siversky uh highly
influential it was too
about the two specific points
i don't think truman was forced to order
the bombing of hiroshima and nagasaki
uh by anyone i think truman
uh i am a great admirer of president
truman i think he was a man of
strong opinions high intelligence and
independent mind and i think he just
decided that if he could end the war by
using
the new atomic weapons against
japanese territory he was going to
rather than
launching an american ground invasion
which uh he was told would
uh costs
well the usual figure is a million
casualties sometimes
a million dead anyhow the figure a
million was about
and truman simply decided to avoid that
uh awful outcome
um
i i
i i i think i really think that's as far
as it goes what about the
emperor of japan offering a surrender
this is a
it's often raised it's a matter that's
often raised nowadays that the japanese
had offered to surrender and that if
their diplomatic
tentagrams are read
carefully particularly their
diplomatic dealings with the russians
before
before russia
entered into the war which they did of
course only in august 1945 just just
before just after sorry just after the
the the atomic bombings
then it's uh
it's said that it's
clear that they were trying to offer
their surrender
many diplomatic historians say that that
is not sustainable it's not a
sustainable position the the the
although there were hints and allusions
to the possibility of surrendering
japanese
diplomatic communications the japanese
never ever came out clearly and said yes
we are offering our surrender
and we will uh
accept your
terms unconditionally which after all
was
the only terms to which the allies were
committed
washington d.c good afternoon uh good
afternoon and thank you very much for
the honor to speak to uh sir john um i
have a question uh regarding israel and
palestine and it is mainly um is there a
real militarily strategic reason for
israel to hang on to the settlements
and if if there is not a serious
strategic
importance of retaining the settlements
were they to
abandon them would that significantly
contribute to the united states
effort to
[Music]
secure iraq and i'll take my answer off
the air and i'm very appreciative thank
you
madam i think you you want to be you
ought to be in the news management
business that sort of extremely acute
pair of questions um
it's almost impossible to speak about uh
israel and palestine
in the united states without uh causing
offense and it's very difficult position
for a foreigner which i am
an englishman in in in america to um
uh
to intervene in in because it's far more
far more of an american
uh issue than it is
a european one let alone an english one
the english after all the british said
said goodbye to palestine and israel in
1948. we said we can't manage it
we are incapable of administering the
mandate any longer and we are
withdrawing and uh we are
not not
interfering in the future affairs of the
this territory so that you know that
that that was the english position the
british position then largely remains
the british position to this day uh and
i think a very sensible one since
it's impossible for a country as tiny as
ours is to have an in any and any
influence unlike the united states
um
well but to be frank yes there let me
say that there is a strategic uh
reason for israel wishing to
uh
hold on to
some
this is my personal opinion
some of the territory where settlements
are established
because of the
uh
vulnerability of jerusalem to
attack from within
the west bank
and to the vulnerability of some of the
long-established
uh israeli urban centers in
in northern israel
uh that that there is an undoubted
strategic reason for
uh wishing to maintain wishing to retain
uh
some of the territory on which
settlements stand i'm certainly not
going to be drawn into the
question of which
settlements should be given up i
personally feel that quite a lot of the
settlements should be given up
and that they're being retained for
political reasons and not for strategic
reasons
but that's a sort of statement which
gets one into trouble
oakland california good afternoon
uh yes hi um
i i have a couple of disparate ques
questions i'm sorry uh uh professor john
which i i think might be unified by
their concern uh with the relationship
between politics and warfare
uh the first one i i wonder
uh what you think the relationship
between
the reagan administration policies and
the collapse of russia
might have been
and secondly
in american
response to september 11th
do you think the term war on terrorism
is legitimate use or is it an
illegitimate metaphorical extension of
the word war
and what do you think of
the american use of the concept of enemy
combatant
uh in our military justice approach to
a response to the situation
three questions really
are all very acute ones the last one
highly sensitive
i think president reagan
quite deliberately set out to bankrupt
the soviet union by
heightening
requiring
the soviets to follow him in increasing
military spending knowing that that
would be uh that
american military spending could be
driven up to levels which the soviets
couldn't couldn't reach
and he was i think quite open about it
uh that was his policy and it worked
that was why the the soviet economic
system uh began to break down and why
uh the followers of brezhnev and
notably gorbachev
had in effect to come to the west and
say um
well could you please agree terms on
which we can cease to compete
it's one of the most successful
non-military strategies that has ever
been pursued
um
about the war on terror as a real war
question mark
um
no i don't think it's a real war but
then there's never been anything like it
before
we've never had a situation in which
anti-state organizations which are not
themselves states
can
deploy
military force at the
level which al-qaeda and other terrorist
organizations do
and of course it's they're not exactly
waging war
but
they can stage acts of war i mean the
attack on the twin tires
uh september the 11th was an act of war
even if it wasn't
part of a war if that doesn't sound
illogical
and
because they can stage acts of war it
requires
their enemies
to behave as if they were in a
themselves in a state of war if you
follow me
um
and that's to go on to your third point
which is the sensitive one
it
it as far as i'm concerned the united
states is
it is perfectly legitimate for the
united states to treat
servants of the
international terrorist organizations
uh as
uh competence
without
uh
[Music]
without legal protection
i know that that's a hard thing to say
and a harsh thing to say but
they are
they have they have entered into
a state of war with the united states or
into the they've
entered into the commission of acts of
war against the united states
without
um
uh
taking any of the legal positions the
the uh
statutory positions which competents
normally do
uh
wearing uniforms uh giving notice of
their
of their intended actions etc etc etc
they have
chosen to behave illegally and if
they're therefore treated by the united
states as beyond the law then that is
their affair it shouldn't concern
the international legal system in my
view
sir john keegan will be with us for
another 45 minutes manhattan you're on
the line go ahead please hello
i commend you on your eloquent
definition and descriptions even
illustrations of fortifications
in the history of warfare you said all
of earth's continents are fortified all
except africa but since then i think the
book i read in the mid 90s since then
historians and archaeologists have
uncovered a 100 foot wall that's about
70 feet wide
deep buried in the forest of nigeria i
think it's called the sumbo eredo war
do you ever upgrade your yearbooks i
would love for that to be upgraded i'm
one of your female readers who started
reading you when i researched my
ancestors and found warriors so i'm very
interested in what is said about
fortifications of cultures and
civilizations thank you well thank you
and i'm always grateful for new
information and i'm afraid i hadn't
heard about this wall in nigeria but of
course i'm not surprised to hear that it
exists because
we're forever discovering
new things about
the past
and uh a wall in nigeria was exactly the
sort of thing one would expect would be
there simply hadn't been found before um
there were by the way other
fortifications in in africa which i
should have been i
i think i meant that there weren't long
systematic fortifications like the great
wall of china um
there
there were
small um
point fortifications in africa
uh constructed for various reasons
um
so
well thank you and i will
if i get around to doing a second
edition of a history of warfare i will
upgrade as you urge me to do so
here is another of the
20 plus books that john keegan has
written six armies in normandy
originally 1982 brought back out with a
special introduction for the 50th
anniversary of d-day we go to san diego
next you're on the air
oh hi um brian yes hello though
fantastic show and a pleasure listening
to sir john and
my supposition would be that
the middle east situation i would think
they would be better served with
in terms of iraq to
make a rock a de facto kurdistan because
there are roughly anywhere from 15 to 20
million kurds in the area and they have
been our only allies that i can see
and we and the what's going on in the
middle east is in fact basically a war
because the wahhabis are pushing all of
this stuff
and until we get those people under
control there's going to be a problem my
second supposition would be after you
created basically a de facto kurdistan
you can call it iraq whatever you want
to call it they are the majority then
you can hold elections so right now the
shias would run the country and they
would side with iran
so the second part would be i think
probably a southern lebanon which was
the kickoff of the war anyway in 1986 or
83 when they blew up all the people in
beirut if they created southern lebanon
then they could create a um
a state to stand between
northern lebanon which is basically run
by syria and the palestinians they
should be created below and the last one
would be that the palestinian state
should be created
just flat out not even deal with what
the boundaries are but i mean give about
give them a state
but say here's your state and we'll talk
from here get the people out of israel
they're blowing everybody else say
here's your state let's go from here
let's talk after we give you a state
because the wahhabis don't want a
palestinian state that's what's causing
the problem thanks
well
um there's an awful lot in the in in
that that question of yours uh
i think what you're really uh
focusing on is the
is the existence and role of minorities
in the middle east
and
it's so difficult for people from
countries like the united states and
britain
to understand how
contentious
minority politics are because
we both
our experience is entirely really of
unified populations the united states
has one of the most culturally unified
populations in in the world and in world
history
and despite the fact that britain it
divides into four with irish scots
english and welsh where
we are culturally one because we all
speak english and uh
uh our cultural differences are much
less
important than our cultural similarities
but to go to a country like iraq as you
mentioned and
you immediately find as you've pointed
out you have to deal with kurds
who are not arabs at all but are
ethnically iranian
and whose language is more akin to
iranian than it is to arabic and then
two important religious
subdivisions of the arab people the the
sunnis of the center
and the much more numerous shia of the
south
who
do not agree about religion at all don't
even agree about the nature of authority
in islam
if i could
sort of
stand back from your point of view and
it applies to what you had to say about
palestine and what you had to say about
lebanon as well i think it's very easy
for westerners to see what looks like
the sensible thing to do
the objectively reasonable thing to do
and say right that's it
this is the reasonable thing to do
and say that's the solution and you
kurds suddenly shear palestinians
israelis
syrians or lebanese if you don't like it
then you must accept that you're in the
wrong
they won't think like that they'll
simply revert to their minority
positions and you'll be back where you
started you have to find some way if
it's possible of trying to
involve them in
the
involve them in the in the solution
not in dictating the solution
to them from the outside
joe broccolo of chicago asks would you
ever consider wright
writing a history of the american civil
war
i am indeed going to write in history of
the american civil war
i have a contract to do so
and
i have begun work on it and i hope to
publish it in
2005.
you still have
excuse me do you still have notes from
your 1957 tour of the battlefield uh i'm
not sure that i made notes in 1957 but
uh
i've certainly i've visited this
i was only 23 i think in there i was uh
and i was
so busy getting to know america and
enjoying myself that i i didn't think i
was very systematic about my visits to
the battlefields but
i've made many many subsequent visits
and i certainly do have notes
uh i
in 19
1994
i
made a visit to the battlefields of
northern virginia in the company of the
then
head of us
the head chief of u.s military his army
chief of u.s military history
who uh gave me the most brilliant tour
of the battlefields particularly
chancellorsville which i made detailed
notes which i've never forgotten
washington dc you're next
mr keegan hello hello uh i am not a
zionist nor am i a phyllo semi as you
put it
you did seem to imply that anyone who
regards uh mr irving as not a very very
good historian end quote would not be
reasonable in your view yet
i have the lipstat transcript in front
of me and there is according to the
court
just example after example hundreds of
examples where as a historian
irving distorts evidence misstates
evidence misconstrues evidence misquotes
evidence
falsifies statistics falsely attributes
conclusions to reliable sources
hardly the work of a good historian for
example
mr irving claims that hitler was
probably the biggest friend the jews
ever had
just with regard to the kristallnacht
one small section of distortions
irving misquotes and skews a reference
from gobel's diary to imply that hitler
had no responsibility for the
kristallnacht
omits a key part of gobel's speech which
would have implied hitler's
responsibility
in trying to present the program as
gobel's point relies on false evidence
claims that people made statements who
did not make statements in suggesting
that hitler did not know about the
pogrom initially misresents
misrepresents the global's diary entry
entirely ignores material which cast
grave doubt on the
plaintiffs that is irving's version of
events i realize we have little time
here but this is a small excerpt
of just innumerable historical
distortions and i wonder apart from the
personal characterizations of those who
regard irving with skepticism as
zionists or philosomites whether purely
from the reasonable and objective
evaluation of him as a historian whether
given the numerous distortions observed
during the trial
despite your eminence whether he should
be regarded
as a good historian or whether you'll
simply write these hundreds of
historical distortions
off to exceptions thank you
well
i've
of course i i think i've made it clear
that i i find
um
many
well
that i that i find irving whenever he
gets onto
the subject of uh
the the treatment of the jews or the
experience of the jews of suffering the
jews
uh in the in the 30s and 40s in the in
the nazi period i find him repugnant
uh
and i do not agree with him of course
not
uh but you i think listening to you or
somebody who hasn't read hitler's war
which is the only book of his i'm really
interested in uh somebody listening to
you talking about
uh
uh his so-called distortion his well
they are undoubtedly distorted his
distortion center would imagine that
that is what hitler's war is about but
hitler's war is in fact about hitler as
a military commander fighting an
enormous war against first the russians
and then the british and the americans
and the uh the the the amount of space
devoted to
uh hitler's treatment of uh
the the his jewish
victims or uh any of his other european
victims is is minute it's tiny
you've completely just bought distorted
the the relative importance of uh hit of
irving's treatment of hitler as military
commander and hitler as persecutor of
the jews in that book in that book only
which is what i'm talking about
his
his overwhelmingly large focus is on
hitler as a military commander and he is
extremely interesting and important on
hitler's performance as a military
commander that's all i'd say
eureka california you're next
hello hello
i'm a retired mechanical engineer and
i'm working on a book
of the um
ports of america historical forts of
america
sure i'm trying to make this short right
the question i have is i'm
i'm uh
concerned about
after the revolution
the
british
soldiers
and the british citizens that went home
or stayed in
writings as to quantities and who stayed
and who left and
where they went etc right yes
is there um
notes to that effect uh recorded
well uh it's very interesting you asked
that question because i think
uh that the the the
the fate of the loyalties the fate of
the loyalists as they're called
um is a is an undercover subject
um
about as we know is
about a third of the population of the
thirteen colonies were either actively
or passively
pro british
that's the usual calculation about a
third were
were rebels
uh or patriots
about a third were
indifferent to try to keep out of it and
about a third were loyalists
uh you can argue with the details but
that's usually that's the proportions
usually estimated
uh
when the british lost and left america
uh
some of the loyalists made their peace
with the new
uh
government
uh
some went to canada
where they became the the the empire
loyalists
and
some went back to britain
some were genuine americans they weren't
never been to britain's but some went to
britain all the same for example
two of the captains
uh who commanded ships in nelson's fleet
at the battle of the nile in 1798 one of
nelson's three great victories were new
yorkers
and one of them i think went on to to
fight at the battle of trafalgar
a numbers of them went on to serve as
officers in the east india company's
army
in in india what would later become the
indian army um
and there there there is a there is a
lot of information about the the
americans in the in the east india
companies army but i don't think i think
you're right i don't think uh
the the story of the loyalists after the
war of the revolution after the defeat
of the british uh has been well enough
told it's certainly not well enough now
i think it's a fascinating story
louisville kentucky
good afternoon hello let me add my voice
to the
chorus
saying thank you for c-span and for this
kind of programming
it's a pleasure to speak with you sir
john keegan my question is about the
troubles in northern ireland
and i will be teaching a course
on irish literature soon to
undergraduate students
and i'm wondering uh what would you say
are the main points about
that conflict which these students
should be introduced to and have you
written on the troubles specifically
and are there works that you would
recommend that i read as part of my
preparation
well now
with a name like keegan you may guess i
am of irish ancestry which indeed i am
uh
you may not guess but i will tell you
that i
if anything even more reluctant to
talk about uh the troubles in northern
ireland than i am to talk about troubles
in israel or
uh david irving i think they're they're
such uh
you know
irresolvable
irresistible contentious
conflicts that uh i'd
really
try to have as little to do with them as
possibly can
um
i would say one thing which is
every cloud has a silver lining they say
and if september the 11th had a single
good
uh effect it was that it's knocked
terrorism on the head in ireland
september the 11th
has given terrorism such a bad name in
europe
that the the former terrorist groups
and in ireland that meant the irish
republican army and the various
protestant paramilitary groups dare not
dare not commit terrorist acts because
of american disapproval
behaving in any way like al-qaeda they
know will attract
the fourth strike condemnation of the
american government and of american
public opinion and they don't risk that
about books to read on the irish
troubles um
[Music]
there are two writers both
uh
both
over
uh sympathetic to the ira but important
nonetheless they know a great deal about
the ira what one an american called jay
bowyer bell and the other an irishman
called
tim pat coogan
uh but
there
are
also works by protestant historians
um roy foster in particular the
the uh
the uh professor of irish history at
oxford
uh which should be read
as a balance
you should tell the audience that the
boo your bell book
was on book notes as was your earlier
book on the history of warfare and
people can get on booknotes.org and get
the transcript of it if you want to get
some background on boo your bell and his
book
wrangle arkansas you're on the air or is
it wrangle alaska
that is wrangle alaska welcome um
i
appreciate this as many of you many
viewers have noted
but and my concern is
uh mideast hatred of western
civilization
and i've appreciated your perspective
and
recently there have been some programs
that have shown
lawrence of arabia and i apologize for
not really
not knowing his name but
there was an agreement between the
british and the french at that time to
divide
asia
how much is that and the later strategic
report support for
um regimes that we considered friendly
to our interest
the cause of current hatred
well that's a very
opposite question the the agreement to
which you refer
uh is called the sykes pico agreement of
um
either 1915 or 1916 sykes was a british
diplomat so it was pico a french
diplomat
they agreed to
create
zones of influence if not of authority
in the post-war middle east
uh which roughly allotted uh syria and
lebanon to the french
uh palestine and jordan and iraq to the
british
meanwhile however they were
and this is i think the the the
the
the cause this is what
has caused arab
suspicion and
and uh
uh post-war discontent meanwhile they
were
promising the same territory
to the
followers of the sharif of mecca
the hashemite ruler or the hashemite
head of family
who
was joining with lawrence of arabia he
put his name right t lawrence
in raising revolt against the ottoman
empire
said
right back at the beginning there was
double dealing
but i don't think that's
the ultimate cause of the trouble i mean
the the
had there not been
uh the balfour declaration and had there
not been fairly large-scale jewish
immigration into the middle east
uh
i think the middle east would
probably
probably not be
the trouble saying that it is that's a
dangerous
dangerous
calculation to suggest but
it's
as i began as i said earlier when
talking about minorities i mean the
problem in the middle east is minorities
it's not boundaries
and it's not natural resources either
if you've just joined us we're talking
with sir john keegan
knighted in the year 2000
born in the year 1934 in london lives in
wiltshire and we're going to show
some video of his home in just a moment
want to show you his first book 1976.
he taught for 26 years
at sandbridge the military academy like
west point
uh which is about 10 miles outside of
heathrow that's right yes uh the uh
airport probably fly over it if you fly
to london from the united states
most of his books are
can be found through penguin paperback
editions and i'm sure on the internet
let's show some video as we take our
next call
of uh
sir john's home over in wiltshire which
is how far from london
125 miles and we're zooming in on his
second floor
office where he spends 10 hours a day
writing and researching next call we go
to new york city go ahead new york uh
good afternoon sir john hello i'm
interested in your appraisal of the
shifting quality of uh military honor
and the question is prompted by an
experience i had in germany in
the middle 60s where i encountered a
chap by the name of evidegograph
einsteidl who was married to elizabeth
von schtaufenberg
the daughter of the man who tried to
blow up hitler right and there was in
his home and in her life
a sense of disquiet
as to whether he was hero
or perhaps traitor
and at dinner in their home which i was
at a few times there was the occasional
[Music]
erect bearing
sales executive who was obviously an ex
military type and whenever this subject
or the war came up the conversation
always switched into german which i
could not speak at all but the the the
sensitivity to that um has fascinated me
and i'd be grateful for your appraisal
of that and of um
in a general sense of how military honor
has changed up until the present day as
well
well
a very
very
interesting but for me sensitive
question
like you i'm a friend of the startenberg
family although i don't know
that side i um i'm a friend of
klaus von stauffenberg the eldest son
and his wife
max tilt
i've stayed with them in germany they've
stayed with us in england
[Music]
they
make a family visit to germany from
wherever they are in the world every
year
on july the 20th there's a there's a
family commemoration
of the bomb plot
you're quite right nevertheless to
indicate that
not all germans regards class french
staff and bag senior the father as a
national hero um
they uh
they feel that uh
to
act against the head of state even if
the head of state was hit during a war
was in some way
a breach of military honor
i'm
i'm
not expressing an opinion i'm merely
saying that i know that that is what is
felt
uh it is one of the most difficult of
all issues in
the life of soldiers in the in the life
of
states
what action is justified against a ruler
who is clearly
in breach of the law of his own country
and the law of nations
more books if you've just joined us from
john kegan a history of warfare
the book of war 25 centuries of great
war writing what was the emphasis for
this book
it's an anthology
which i'd been asked to do by
an american editor of whom i was very
fond
and
i i enjoyed doing it i tried to give it
some shape i think anthologies
the difficulty with anthologies is that
they're very often merely
unorganized collections of pieces of
writing and uh i tried to
show a development
in
the nature of
of war in
the personal experience of war by the
way in which i organize the pieces
with some success i think i'm not not
making more claim for it than that
indianapolis you're next
indianapolis you're on the air go ahead
please hello hello though yes uh it's a
pleasure to meet you and it's been a
delight and pleasure to read your book
so thank you very much thank you uh my
question is is there a particular uh
battle or war or even a general subject
in uh military history that
you believe has not been
uh sufficiently covered and that would
be a subject for an intriguing book and
if so um why do you think it's not been
sufficiently
covered golly
um
in my lifetime
military history has uh
uh
expanded almost like the world economy
uh it was
it was a very very minor interest
and not very well done when i started
out in the
in the 50s really
and it was very very difficult
as a young military historian to find
uh
books that you felt you had to read the
the all
the good books were very few in number
and there were big patches
nothing almost nothing had been done on
the anthropology of war for example
which has always been
and has become
even more a great interest of mine there
was very little on
uh
proper study of uh
armies and governments
uh there was very little about uh
the social aspects of war particularly
things like military medicine
which i think are tremendously important
um very little about the
the
post-war consequences
particularly how
servicemen ex-servicemen are treated and
so on all that now has been done and
there's there's
less and less blank
there are fewer and fewer blank spaces
on the map
i really am i really cannot think of a
an untreated or under-treated subject
uh perhaps that will stimulate
callers to
telephone in and remind me of things
i've forgotten
here's the email of the day
from elizabeth in palm coast florida
i am six a 16 year old girl who loves
studying history
my question is politically economically
and socially
most of history is pretty unpleasant
do you believe that people suffer from
some psychological flaw
that compels us to oppress and destroy
one another for example isn't it
interesting how a few defective people
can get power and keep it and kill
millions of people
thank you well she's a very clever girl
and i think she should stick out the
study of history because she's
put her finger on something absolutely
crucial right away
the
tendency of bad people to rise to the
top
is of course not a new idea but she puts
it very well
why it happens is a
perennial mystery
who was it you said
in order for evil to triumph it is only
necessary for good men to do nothing
uh i don't think it was burke
although it is a birkin idea
but of course that
that's the point
uh
most people
historians of course
like historians concentrate on
uh
the
dangerous the disreputable the
regrettable
in exactly the same way as journalists
concentrate on uh
divorces and not happy marriages i mean
the happy marriages are news divorces
are news
um
but
that's
unrepresentative i mean
even there there is even in in in in in
the united states or my own country
where there's such a high divorce rate
nevertheless there are more stable
marriages than unstable marriages
um
and there
although there's a
dreadful lot of dissent and and
contention in the world there is also an
enormous amount of cooperation and
tranquility and harmony
uh and i think that should always be set
against
the sort of thing that gets into the
history books
how long have you been married
43 years this december what date next
year do you turn 70
may the 15th
are you looking forward to it not
particularly
there's not much you can do about you
just
everett washington you're on the air
yeah so john hello
i was born may 17 1933 really so you're
363 days older than i am i've got you by
a year by gad right so john do you know
a place called bentley prairie
in watford
no i don't world war two is where all
the mapping was drawn from the bombers
and all that sort of oh
norfolk was where the bombers were
stationed of course uh yes yes well it's
just uh it's just outside of watford
near stanmore right oh yes okay
well the reason for the call i was
stationed in the raf in 1951 when i was
doing my conscription right
and the number one fpu was there the
film production unit oh yes do you
remember her name uh sir philip juba yes
of course well uh we're working on two
films called um
uh
the dam busters yes
and uh the other one escapes my mind for
the moment but i was just wondering the
the these thousands and thousands and
thousands of feet of film that were
there negatives you'll have in the
prince original negatives
uh
i wondered whatever became about
material because goodness me uh just all
the daylight bombing raids over germany
corrupts the evening
uh the ball bearing plants i think we
were involved a little bit with the
victory at sea
uh and so on i wonder if if you've any
idea uh what might have happened to all
that material
i'll hang up and listen to you thank you
sir thank you well i hope that it's
been been stored in an archive either at
the raf museum at hendon or perhaps at
the imperial war museum
uh the trouble is that historical
material
uh
owned by governments
all too easily gets thrown away
in a fit of uh house clearing you know
when they move people move offices or
the uh
establishments are closed on and uh
somebody says oh this is a this lot of
old paper or this box of old negatives
is just cluttering the place up get rid
of it
i've known that happen i'm afraid to say
in three or four crucial cases and it's
once you've done it it can't be
retrieved but i'm afraid it is done your
recommendation to that 16 year old girl
who says she likes history
and she wants to be a historian what's
the best way to get there
oh keep reading
uh
history is a is a
whatever
fashions and fans there have been in my
lifetime and there have been many
history is a literary subject history is
a is a
it's a word subject
and
at her age at 16
she didn't bother with original
documents with original manuscripts
she should
read as many printed books
of the right sort as she can find your
favorite or most interesting book you've
read in the last couple months
oh i'm reading a book i haven't finished
it yet called stallion the court of the
last tsar by simon seabag mount
montefiore
which is about the
it's both a political account of the
bolshevik the rise to power of the bot
the rise
the early years of power of the
bolsheviks and
a picture of their
intimate family life and it's horrifying
i mean
stalin was
arguably a nastier man than hitler and
uh
[Music]
the account of how he
could cultivate his own happiness in his
own family life while
consigning hundreds of thousands of
people often his own intimates
to
horrible treatment in the prison camps
in the gulag is is is terrifying
montefiore is the author seabag
montefiore
uh simon seabag montefiore
uh it was widely noticed in england i
hope it's i'm sure it'll be published in
the united states ann arbor you're on
hello brian hi hello sir john hello
thank you for taking my question
i've written them down so hopefully i
won't babble too much right um
why was hitler appointed as german
chancellor and what would have happened
to hitler in his nazi movement
if he had not been appointed to that
office and also
why for the longest time did no one pay
attention to churchill when he was in
parliament that hitler
should be viewed as dangerous and lastly
do you allowed your dangerous cat to
live inside the house or is she an
outdoor cat
right um i'll answer the third question
last we have three cats
oscar the dangerous one uh i don't know
where he lives and i can't say i care
much i i'm looking at the finger he
nearly bit off
our two lovely american cats
who are called
uh cecil and monty uh
uh come and go as they please they spend
a lot of time in the house
being
new england cats they have this
enormously thick winter coat they don't
seem to feel the cold and
so they're in and out as they choose
about hitra
um
he wasn't really well i suppose he was
appointed but the point hindenburg as
president of germany felt obliged to
uh offer him the chancellorship because
by that stage in january 1933
uh the nazi party although
a minority party was in in that no party
had a majority
in the in the uh in the german
parliament in the right strike
the the nazi party had more seats than
any of the other parties did so
hindenburg felt felt obliged to offer
him the chancellorship
uh why wasn't churchill heard because
his message was uncomfortable as he
himself said at the time of munich that
he couldn't
blame what he called the brave british
people for being relieved that
chamberlain had signed the munich
agreement
that
czechoslovakia had been sacrificed to
to german power but he said nevertheless
this is a
this is a a a policy for which we will
pay a bitter price we will regret it
and
we will wish that we hadn't done it
but
although
church was always listened to he was
never shouted down
accuracy he was shouted down after the
war he never shouted down
before the war
uh he was always listened to with
respect and he commanded
a serious audience wherever you spoke
but nevertheless the british didn't
really want
to hear him because what he was saying
was
despite our economic difficulties which
were many we must make sacrifices to
rearm and we must be ready to fight
germany again as we fought germany in
1914 and the british didn't want to do
that they only did it when they there
was no alternative
in september 1939
las vegas good afternoon
hi brian hi hi sir hello it's been
wonderful to listen to you
uh my question is about the military
strategists of world war one yes yeah
did they study the experience in the
american civil war and if so why did
they attempt all those feudal uh frontal
charges is was it simply that they had
contempt for their american counterparts
or was there something else going on and
i also have three cats so i'm even
fonder of you and right thanks again and
thank you thank you brian for the
wonderful programming bye-bye
um
this is a subject to go back to a theme
we've discussed already this is a
subject the influence of the american
civil war on the europeans is a subject
which has been uh
widely studied there was a wonderful
book published in the 1960s
called the military legacy of the civil
war
uh uh and it studied the the the
the way in which the germans the french
and the british
uh
studied the american civil war and what
they learnt from it and the conclusion
is that they
in their different ways
each of them rejected
the lessons of the american civil war
which were that
untrained mass armies could uh
achieve high levels of
military efficiency in the field that
industrial power was
of ultimately greater importance and
military power etc etc
and uh
the subject still commands great
interest among
european military historians
uh
uh um the answer is still the same that
the the europeans
were
so immersed in their own experience of
warfare and what they
in their own beliefs about warfare
above all that it
uh
wars were won by
trained
long-served longer service armies and uh
professional leaders that they
they couldn't bring themselves to
accept the evidence of the american
civil war which was contrary to that
four minutes left downers grove illinois
you're on uh yes uh hello brian it's
good to talk with you and to uh tweet uh
sir john hello
uh hi my name is donald lacera i'm a
retired luke 10 colonel in the us army
right
and
i served in world war ii and i'm 90
years of age oh good congratulations sir
and if i if i
sir john correctly the basic explanation
of war springs from human nature
that is it's based on human nature
although there is simultaneously in what
he has been saying
recognition of war as being
a highly institutionalized
phenomenon
underlying what i think is sir john's
approach it seems to me is an implicit
acceptance of war as an inevitable
and unescapable
instrument of national policy and it is
that that i wanted to
comment on and ask a question
that is it seems to me to be an
unexamined proposition
well what as an instrument
is learning behavior that's recognized
you mentioned legalities of war laws of
war
and
rules regarding the use of weapons and
when and not to use them so it's all
learned behavior
and perhaps
inevitably
there is a justification of war as an
instrument of national policy caller i'm
going to have to let you go because
we've got one more call and i want uh
well for john
you've skewered me really i find it very
very difficult to disagree with you but
um and i'm always uh trying to get off
the hook on this point but i
don't think war is uh
uh inevitable uh
and i don't think man is
naturally
but is condemned by his nature to fight
wars the way i get out of it is by
saying that of course all man mankind
has a has a capability for violence and
a potentiality for violence but is not
naturally violent now
reconciling those two positions is
difficult but i've spent a lot of my
life trying to do it last call las vegas
nevada you're on the air
uh sir john it's a pleasure it's a
thrill to talk to you hello sir thank
you
uh my name is michael jordan i'm a
physician and i have a particular
interest in the health of uh general lee
specifically
and i know that
that you're going to be coming out with
a book on the american civil war
have you come across anything in your
research to indicate the uh health of
general lee at gettysburg
no not at all but might i say that uh uh
it's a great pleasure to speak to an
american doctor an american physician
because curiously
um a great deal of mine
transatlantic mail comes from american
doctors uh
uh who seemed to me to have a quite
remarkable interest in military history
um
lee
leaves health general health during the
the civil war
was adequate
uh he did didn't suffer
um
any physical or mental uh
didn't display any physical or mental
uh symptoms in the way that some others
did not as for example longstreet is
alleged to have suffered from a sort of
nervous crisis throwing get us back uh
but i don't think i think lee was frail
but he you know he's his life after the
civil war was quite
brief
uh
uh
he he wasn't his death wasn't brought
about by disease as uh
or disorder as grants was good grant
died of of cancer because he was
addicted to cigars and
had
throat cancer
that's not the case with lee but i i
don't think flea was really
physically very strong and perhaps the
trauma of the war
uh
and his frailty
contributed to
is quite
uh abrupt death after the war was over
there have been more than 40 books and
this is the latest
intelligence and war and knowledge of
the enemy from napoleon to al-qaeda our
guest has been sir john keegan he's been
with us for the last three hours and we
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed and thank all the callers it's a
pleasure to speak to them to our
audience have a good afternoon
next month on in depth douglas brinkley
he's written books on fdr jimmy carter
rosa parks and henry ford